[Music]
so
i keep thinking about this cosmopolitan
socialist idea which i wrote about
and against the web and um
what was interesting in that was i i
think that that
model is definitely the one we need
this cosmopolitanism with a ground in
materialist politics and marxist
analysis of the economic base
is the best way to go about things we're
in a global society we're in a deeply
interconnected one
we have to overcome all sorts of
legacies
of division abuse and depression
but we also have to create cohesion and
integration and actually
build models for things that are better
and part of how we do that
is by really looking for synthesis
looking for points of reference
i you know there is like a
spiritual for lack of a better word
element to this
[Music]
hello plastic pills listeners we hope
that you're all enjoying
uh the emergence of summer uh wherever
you happen to be
today we have a guest megan day uh she
is a writer for jacobin
who i've read for a long time so this is
really exciting for me
and we're joined with victor as well and
we're gonna be talking about
cosmopolitan socialism
so thanks a lot for coming on the pill
pod megan it's really great to have you
thanks for having me so one of the
things i just kind of wanted to throw
out there first
is this concept of cosmopolitan
socialism
has deep roots uh in the left-wing
tradition but it's probably best
associated now
with michael brooks uh who argued for a
kind of cosmopolitan socialism at the
end of his book against the web
which is actually really a critique of
different right-wing thinkers that we've
talked about on the show before uh but
he kind of characterizes it
less as a kind of set of policies uh and
more as an attitude
it reminded me a lot of the old roman
saying that
nothing human is foreign to me uh that
was the kind of outlook he adopted
in this book that he's somebody who'll
read cornell west and the data ching
and karl marx and rather than
discriminating between them he'll try to
find something of value in each of those
writings is that the kind of sense that
you have of what a cosmopolitan
attitude might be victor yeah well i
mean i i think what's interesting about
the word cosmopolitanism is uh
even up to now i mean i as a phd student
i grade a class
on that covers a lot of like critical
race theory stuff and i noticed that
there
cosmopolitanism is kind of a dirty word
a little bit
and i think it still has a tradition
like a mixed tradition of being
associated with some
some like political or attitude that's
supposed to erase difference and
therefore like be kind of violent
towards particular differences but i
think what michael brooks is doing is
maybe trying to bring that
uh to make that a less dirty word and i
wonder if you had thoughts about that
megan actually
yeah i think that's precisely right so i
was listening to an old
podcast that michael was on where he was
sort of explaining his
use of the term and he acknowledged that
it might
sound to today's ears at least in our
sort of
lay discourse it might sound a little
bit like he's talking about
like brexiteers in london like you know
cosmopolitan
like when fancy people hang out in
coastal cities or like big international
cities
um and it's it's not that the term as
he's using it is devoid of the
connotation
of large kinetic international cities
it's just that he's not using it to
denote like cultural
elites or something like that which i
think is how it's commonly used
um instead as he explained
his his idea of cosmopolitan socialism
is really meant to evoke the idea that
in
uh large cities going all the way back
through the ages
you would find different groups of
people intermingling with each other
and taking bits and pieces of each
other's culture and actually really
coming to understand each other's
humanity through sheer
exposure obviously not without the
superimposition of incredibly violent
hierarchies constantly and always right
but that people's exposure to each other
and their openness to
adopting elements of each other's
culture might actually
um provide a a window into how to build
solidarity and how to actually
politically break down those hierarchies
so that seemed to me to be what he was
trying to get across with the term
cosmopolitan
but then there's another element to this
too which is just the actual
term cosmopolitan meaning you know a
citizen of the cosmos a citizen of the
universe a citizen of everywhere a
universal citizen it's a sort of
a call for a new universalism on the
left
one that doesn't ignore or erase the
particular but that actually sees it as
a a laudable goal to try to find
unearth our shared humanity right and i
do think that the reason that he feels
that might be important is because if
you look at the
popularity of the you know the um
intellectual dark web and various right
wing figures
you see that they are really feeding off
of
and gaining a lot of um momentum because
the left does seem to reject that kind
of universalism in favor of you know
particularism
and it causes people who bristle at that
to look for alternatives right so i
think that's the reason why it's tacked
on to the end of the
against the web or at least why he
started thinking about it in that
context
yeah i think that's very true and it is
worth noting that the original
connotation or denotation um of
cosmopolitanism
uh was in the greek so cosmos meaning
universe
and polos being city or community right
so you were literally
a citizen of the universe or you're a
part of one city the
totality of humanity and the original
connotation
in the philosophical literature going
through stoicism for example through
people
like adam smith was really this attitude
that look you know i'm going to
embrace the wisdom of the ages wherever
it comes from
i'm going to try to be open-minded in my
approach to difference rather than
closed-minded
which is what you often see for instance
with nationalism right
let alone imperialism but i think one of
the reasons why some people in the left
are reticent to embrace the cosmopolitan
label is
it's really become dissociated in
modernity from this classical
connotation
where instead it's associated with a
kind of militant even imperial liberal
universalism
uh the way that i usually see people use
the term cosmopolitanism is to refer to
someone like
john stewart mills right who would say
things like we should be cosmopolitan
liberals but if that means we need to
intervene in india and colonize it to
bring it into the family of civilized
nations uh that's what we need to do
and contemporaneously of course we can
think of neoliberalism as a kind of
cosmopolitan doctrine
stressing the need to incorporate
everybody around the globe and the
cosmopolitan family of market nations
and obviously we don't want that uh and
so i can understand the temptation of
many on the left to try to resist these
kinds of cosmopolitanism
right or internationalism however you
want to frame it but i really do think
that
the kind of classical cosmopolitanism uh
michael was talking about
is a lot more consistent with our value
system right uh
cherishing humanity for its own sake
want to make sure that everyone
regardless of where they come from has a
fair shot at life
and i can break down some of my own
thoughts on how that could be achieved
but i just want to know if you think
that's true also victor is this
yeah so i think um i mean you made me
think of a couple things
uh there one one of them was just you
know
you're reminding me of my sometimes
frustration with some corners of the
left that it's like as soon as
a term gets associated with something
right you see the same thing with
liberalism
like it in some corners it's like that
just means neoliberalism therefore
like we want to be against the liberals
and that's why we see on
on like a lot of cringy like twitter
accounts right that have like
the hammer and sickle it's just like
everything liberal is bad but i guess
like i think
what's nice about what michael brooks
was trying to do with cosmopolitanism is
like
take one of those terms right in this
case being cosmopolitanism and
be like no no there's actually like good
versions of it there's actually like
ways in which this term
uh can actually encompass something
that's super important to any
left-wing ethic and you know to me i
just see it as
something that i've always been
interested since i started my my studies
was just like trying to recover this
concept of the common good you know i
think it's so important to try to
uh recapture it and i did notice i did
read
the article you sent us megan uh about
unionization
efforts and uh yeah of course i can see
why it's totally relevant there right
this idea that uh
you know a multi-racial union uh where
people
who at the time right this was of course
late uh late 19th century early 20th
century right can
can find their material common interest
um and i think you know it made me think
about
um today a lot of things that i believe
in
as left-wing causes that i wish were
framed
more along the lines of common interest
and i have in mind things like defund
the police
and even like prison abolition which are
two things that i
i just worry that they're framed too
much around like particularism
right of the way that those things
disproportionately affect
uh like one segment of the population
race usually and of course that needs to
be talked about
but i feel like there's an opportunity
with those things to be like no actually
if we
you know radically reform prisons or
change the way we do policing that's
actually gonna be good for everybody
right like we're all gonna uh we're all
gonna benefit from that
framing it that way it seems like there
might be an opportunity and
you know i wonder if you had thoughts
about that yeah
that i think that you're hitting on
something which is that on the left
today to just put it in very plain terms
it does seem like there's a very loud
contingent of people
who think that the idea that something
would be good for everybody is actually
kind of insulting
because we have because we have so much
grotesque inequality
that they actually would rather
emphasize the ways than which it is
specifically good for the people who
usually bad things happen to
and that might also be bad for the
things that people might be bad for the
people to whom good things usually
happen do you see what i'm saying
so it does seem like there's an emp
there's an emphasis on flipping the
script
like if you're at the bottom of the sort
of um
social or political hierarchy we're
gonna elevate you to the top and if
you're at the top we're gonna suppress
you to the bottom
and that seems to be the mode through
which left-wing politics is
often articulated now um that is in
contrast to a kind of
universalist politics that says that as
my one of my favorite um
quotes from socialist history is the
sort of british labor movement
motto which is that the cause of labor
is the hope of the world
the the working class is the universal
class we're not all in favor with the
working class because it is better than
all the other classes it's just simply
the case
that the working class is is
strategically located and is big enough
and has the self-interest enough that
were it to unite to overthrow the
structures that are oppressing it
all of us would be liberated from
capitalism from imperialism
and so on um and so this kind of
universalism seems to have been
buried under an emphasis on um
you know how to um i guess
center you often hear language like
centering marginalized voices
and things like that these are perfectly
understandable and i also want to say
while i'm on the topic of it being
understandable that
i agree with what you said earlier about
um a sort of hollow
um universalism that the especially the
like center right
is is known for um the center right will
often speak
about um you know use use the language
of universalism to actually sort of like
shove capitalists and imperialist
hegemony down everybody's throats right
like think about um
the kind of um universalism or
internationalism that you see at a place
like davos the kind of like we all came
from every corner of the world here
together to
continue oppressing the people of all
lands right and uh
clearly clearly that's not the type of
universalism that we want to pursue
but we don't need to chuck the whole
thing out and i think that that's
something that
michael was really getting at um in his
in his section on this and against the
web is that we don't want to throw out
the baby with the bath water and in fact
the idea of a common good and the idea
of a universal benefit through struggle
is something that is not just um
a proud legacy of the left but it's
actually critical to our
success and that's the reason why i sent
you guys that article about
um that that union the the triple
alliance of unions in new orleans which
i'm happy to explain now because i
assume your readers have not read it um
yeah yeah we'll post a link though okay
good so let me just
give you let me just explain the actual
um you know the the content of the
article so that
you can see how it relates um and one of
the reasons why i wanted to send this to
you guys because i remember michael
responding very favorably to it
right actually when it came out which
was not too long before he died and i
think that it's because it resonated
with some of these themes
um so in new orleans in the 1860s white
dock workers were
actually um they were immigrant you know
mostly german english immigrant dock
workers were actually anti-slavery
for completely self-interested reasons
there was nearby labor that was not
being compensated with money and of
course it was driving their own wages
down
so they believed that you know you
should eliminate this practice of
slavery
didn't seem to benefit them anyway um
and that would hopefully
result in raising their wages with
raising wages across the board which
would redown to their benefit
um so slavery is abolished right um and
then
suddenly you have of course they hadn't
necessarily thought about this
um you have ex-slaves who are completely
disenfranchised they're completely
destitute they have no property they
have
they have nothing um but the clothes on
their backs and they show up on the on
the docks in new orleans and now they
want to work on the docks
in new orleans and they're working for
way less pay because they can't command
high pay because they have no structural
leverage in society and because there's
so much racism
so um this is pissing off the white dock
workers right because
um now they're still having the same
issue maybe not as bad as before but now
they're competing against
low paid labor on the docks so they
whereas they had been essentially
abolitionists
in a space of about a decade these white
dock workers were actually saying things
like
send these black people back to africa
like they had become incredibly racist
like overnight just because the
the situation had changed right um and
this created created a situation
throughout the rest of
throughout the next three decades or so
where white and black doc workers
were um very they had uh tense relations
shall we say um
usually unidirectional tense relations
um
on the docks in new orleans and the
white workers would not allow the black
workers to um join their unions
um they they uh tried to stay as far
away from them as possible
um and they were constantly trying to
convince the bosses not to hire them and
so on
um so the black dock workers um form
their own unions right
and this creates an issue where the boss
is
um whenever one group is goes on strike
the bosses can just call the others in
us
as strike breakers right white workers
go on strike now you've got the black
workers coming in as strike breakers and
the same is true in the reverse
um the black workers are consistently
saying like we've got to stop this you
guys have got to get over your racism
because it's not working
eventually the white workers actually
realize that um this is true
they're continually losing they they
can't actually
keep it up this level of segregation is
undermining
their ability to actually embody
solidarity and practice
to their own mutual benefit to their
common good
and so they create a a formation called
the triple alliance which i believe is
two white unions and one black union on
the new orleans docks
which encompasses everybody and um the
triple alliance goes on strike together
for the first time
and it's like a light bulb goes off
guess what if you go on strike together
then you shut you shut the whole thing
down you know they won like miraculous
um you know miraculous concessions from
the bosses and so on i believe it was a
general strike in new orleans at the
time so actually black and white workers
throughout the city were inspired by
this enough to walk off the job in
various other sectors and so on
um and from this point onward on the new
orleans docks
they decided that they were going to
institute a policy
that um black and white workers needed
to work together
on shifts they called it a half and half
policy
they basically realized overnight that
the level of segregation that they had
been imposing on themselves was
undermining their ability to actually
improve
their conditions and so they remedied
this with something called a half and
half policy
which is that every single shift was
supposed to have both black and white
workers on it
to reintegrate or to integrate for the
first time these two groups that had
been kept apart
um which had resulted in in both groups
essentially being economically punished
right
um and so from from that point onward
that was that was the policy on the new
orleans docks i could go into it more
it's very interesting it's sort of
there's some interesting jim crow stuff
that happens later on
but the point that i want to make is
that the spirit of
solidarity is is not it's not just a
value that we hold
um for like squishy moral reasons though
i think we should
right it's also it's also the case that
that's the only path
forward um for us to actually
win against the tiny minority that is in
control of
everything is coming together and that
means finding common good where
perhaps it seems elusive which it
certainly did in the racist south after
the civil war
right um and so and i also think there's
another lesson in here which is that
people you you can't you can't
scrub out racism just through sheer
exposure
but if you are insisting on segregation
you are insisting on a certain degree of
racism if that makes sense
so like integration is not a silver
bullet but it is a precondition for
anti-racism
and i think that the reason that's
important to bring up
is that um i don't want to put it too
harshly but it does seem on the left
today that there
are certain ways in which segregation
like um like various forms of like
self-imposed segregation are kind of in
vogue
um and i think that we should actually
push against that i think that we should
be
pushing for people who are different
from one another
to spend as much time with each other
thinking about how they can
achieve mutual benefit and achieve the
common good as possible and that that
actually will go a long way towards some
kind of anti-racist agenda so that's the
reason i tell you this
whole parable about the new orleans
stock workers i think you can see why it
connects to the idea of cosmopolitan
socialism now
yeah i know for sure that seems really i
i couldn't agree more yeah i mean
i think that's really i find i find i
find the the this
this sort of like new i like you know
putting it delicately like like kind of
self-imposed
the way you put it you know um it's
segregation yeah it worries me it's
something i definitely worry about on
the left so yeah i'm glad you i'm glad
you mentioned it and agree strongly with
that actually when i was reading your
piece
it reminded me of some of the criticisms
i would make of somebody like john judas
so for our readers who don't know john
judith is the author of the socialist
awakening
and he puts forward this argument that
socialists shouldn't be
internationalists
because ultimately the only way to
achieve things like high levels of
unionization
and high quality of life for workers in
the united states is through the
auspices of the nation state and we have
to prioritize people our own nationals
over concern with others and kind of
what i was thinking about
megan uh when i was reading your article
is how some of the reasons that uh you
draw you develop in that article could
be applied to kind of
criticize judas and his position uh not
just squishy moral reasons as you put it
uh but also strategic ones because what
i was thinking is that well
that's a really difficult thing to
actually do today because if we try to
achieve better conditions for workers in
our own country
as it were uh then capital and many
different firms are just going to leave
and go somewhere else
or they can exploit labor in other parts
of the world right so the only way that
we could actually achieve
genuine uh democratic socialism in one
country would be to try to achieve it
everywhere
or at least achieve relatively high
standards uh in the workplace across the
globe
which of course is what capital doesn't
want to see happen right so i'm
wondering what you think of that
argument
do you think that what you're talking
about in the article could apply
beyond just like the kind of
unionization issue in the united states
to
the international terrain that we see
right now and some of the arguments that
some democratic socialists will make
uh arguing that we should have a kind of
nation-state socialism
yeah i think i think that you're right
about that i mean obviously michael
meant for it to be an argument not just
for universalism but for
internationalism um specifically and i
think that's for that very reason i
guess
to connect the sort of like um the micro
level and the macro level
if you think about this um this common
slogan on the left which
well on the i guess you could say the
very very broad left i would say it's
more associated with like radical
liberals
um is to stay in your lane right um
there's a lot of chastising people to
stay in their lane um essentially to not
approach people
um who um are different from them in a
spirit
of you know inquiry or even um
solidarity sometimes gestures of
solidarity are sometimes actually
like um waved away as being somehow sort
of
um unasked for or offensive um and
that's pretty common on the left
unfortunately in the united states today
so just think about that the whole stay
in your lane concept it does seem if you
actually blow that up into a general
principle and then apply it to
what the question of how building
socialism in one country or many
countries you're getting this
theory that the best way to achieve
socialism is to simply stay in our lane
our lane being the united states of
america right and then if everybody else
stays in their lane then we can all
individually advance our own projects
and eventually they will weave together
into some sort of
better hole than the whole that we have
now um and
i i think that the idea of cosmopolitan
socialism is one of an interlacing
right both on the very personal level
like from all the way from the micro
personal level like you should be
exposed to different kinds of people
from yourself
you should seek to expose yourself to
different kinds of people from yourself
in a spirit of honest
and respectful curiosity
and um empathy right and it's
and and that's how you're going to you
know develop
a coherent perspective that can allow
you
to implement practices in your own life
that can actually
build solidarity and community um
strategically and the same is true on a
national level which is that we need to
be interlacing with people from
different cultures and other countries
and developing a shared perspective
together that can actually allow us to
develop practices that actually embody
the spirit of solidarity
um so i guess i agree that um it's it's
applicable to international context and
i think that you can sort of
run it run the principle all the way up
and down the scale from micro to macro
and it's it holds pretty consistently
yeah i think so as well um no go ahead
victor
i was just gonna say uh i mean yeah when
i was reading the article i also thought
about how a lot of the arguments that
are made
about like that worry about borders
right is like the more more people are
gonna come in and then they're gonna
lower wages or whatever and it made me
think about uh just
how yeah how analogous i guess at the
time when when slavery ended in black
started joining i
was like a similar dilemma but uh yeah i
think your article nicely explains
um some of the the answer towards that
but i was
thinking about i think you you touched
on we've touched on it a couple times
like i think there's like really like a
a difficult tension
uh with between i guess particularism
and universalism in these
in like i guess like how are we gonna
properly do
left-wing struggle because i think you
know somebody that probably all of us
are sort of
opposed to on the left somewhat this
this attitude that worries about
um you know being being uh you know
staying in our lane as you put it
i get i think you know a lot of the
rationale for that i think the argument
that they would make would be you know
we have to worry about things like
cultural colonialism right if we hang
around with
you know if if if i just like you know
don't
uh find my space you know with with my
kind of people
then i'm gonna be absorbed into this
sort of like white hegemonic culture
like i think that's the worry and
there's definitely something to that
so that's why i say it kind of like it
remains like a somewhat of a puzzle but
i sti i
i personally think that um
the common good seems so much more
important i suppose and you know this
came up in one of your other articles
megan too i think when you were
uh talking about it was the one about um
the trump i wish i don't have the the
title
oh the culture war one yeah the cultural
one right and i think i was gonna say
the same thing
yeah exactly so that one you know you
you talk about people
i think you were identifying this
tension between
like an attachment to culture versus our
material interests and
uh i don't you like how do you think
about that puzzle i've tried to lay out
there i'd like to frame it as somewhat
different way i think in your article
about trump with the culture war
uh you really elegantly pointed out how
a lot of times these cultural issues are
used as
wedges uh to break break up
working-class solidarity uh and i think
that's a serious issue that we have to
be concerned about
and i think also for tactical and moral
reasons like we've been expressing uh
that's one of the good reasons why we
should embrace a kind
of universalism uh in order to fight
against uh
plutocratic power amongst other kinds of
oppression uh but i think that one of
the worries that people have
and victor you gesture to this is that
the kind of cosmopolitanism that's going
to emerge on the left if we do that
is going to be superficial at best uh
and expropriative
at worst you can think of things like
cultural appropriation
right and i wanted to talk to michael
about this uh
because you know it's one of the
thoughts i had when i was reading this
book and sadly we'll never get to have
that conversation
uh but slavajis who our listeners will
know we talk about quite a bit
uh has a good criticism of this where he
says one of the problems with
liberal cosmopolitans is that they want
the fat-free sugar-free
diet version of other cultures right
something that's
not really different in a radical way
and doesn't challenge your convictions
and he says if we really want to be
cosmopolitans we need to learn to
appreciate the other in their radical
alternative
now i think that there's problems with
this kind of claim not least of which is
the kind of
how radical radical authority can be um
i think it's sometimes overstated in his
work
and the ambiguity of what that would
mean also yeah exactly
and i think you know there's people have
more in common than they do uh
that divides them in my opinion at least
but how do you think we would respond to
this how do we avoid things like
cultural appropriation
not appreciating the other in their
alterity uh expropriating their culture
for ourselves uh in a kind of demeaning
way
yeah i mean i think that cosmopolitan
socialism at its heart also
and i don't know maybe i didn't
emphasize this enough earlier but it
it really stresses the degree to which
people's differences
should be celebrated and enjoyed and
like shared rather than flattened and
homogenized and erased
like that's a very very important
distinction i think that the
the idea of cosmopolitan socialism as i
understand it from michael's perspective
was
like to imagine where he wanted people
to be imagining some of the
some of the great cities today and the
way that people who are very different
from each other and um co-mingle with
each other in those cities while also
preserving
what's distinct about their cultures um
and so i i don't know if that sounds
sort of like
hand wavy or like a cop-out to say like
both and you know what i mean but that i
think that's the truth to be honest i
mean i think that like there's just
we had mentioned it earlier there's a
version of of quote-unquote cosmopolitan
cosmopolitanism that really is about
like um
universalizing dominant
culture and dominant values um
and that's not the thing that michael is
talking about he's talking about like
i guess you could imagine it um as a
sort of like kinetic
process of like encountering and trading
and evolving on a cultural level
i also i've okay i'm going to stumble
through this because i've never actually
talked about this
before this used this example before but
it just popped into my mind
a minute ago when you were talking um
i'm trying to think of an example from
my own life of where there was a
cultural issue that actually made me
feel like a genuine pang
of like hey wait a second i actually i
actually care about that as a person who
has like a marginalized identity right
and we all feel that and i think that's
very legitimate so here's an example i
read
an article recently about um how
there are like very few lesbian bars in
new york city
and even fewer across the country um
yes um they're the the lesbian bar is
like a dying institution
right um and what and i personally
was like damn that sucks lesbian bars
are awesome i spent time in them when i
was younger it was very important for me
right like i don't anymore but like i
don't even drink anymore and i'm in a
long-term relationship but you know i
mean
it was important for me to hang out in
lesbian parts when i was younger um
so that's a cultural issue that i
genuinely care about and i wouldn't say
that the type of cosmopolitan socialism
that we're talking about would simply
try to say like well whatever you can
just go to another bar
right just there's a lot of bars that
have like you could just go to another
buyer no i mean i think we want things
like that right like we want people to
be able to have their own
spaces that where they can create their
own culture and enjoy their own culture
right
um but this is what i think is the crux
of the cosmopolitan socialism
question it's not that you should simply
eliminate all the lesbian bars and
everyone has to just go hang out in
whatever
other bars where everybody else is
hanging out it's that in order
to preserve the lesbian bar as an
institution
you would actually need to have a mass
politics which lesbians are
far too small of a percentage of the
population to actually
affect on their own that pushed back
against the forces
of not of patriarchy not of like
toxic masculinity and not of
heteronormativity but frankly of
the um uh incredibly high real estate
prices that have made it impossible to
maintain bars that cater to a small
portion of clientele
and so like that's that's what happened
to the lesbian bar that i used to go to
in san francisco the lex
lexington club is i used to go there
after work and play pool and it was just
like a blast i was in my early 20s and
i met friends there i met people that
dated there and so on
and the lexus no more i went to its
goodbye party it was very sad
um and the reason why is that they
couldn't afford their rent and also
furthermore a lot of the people who used
to go to that bar moved out of san
francisco
because um san francisco has become a a
major tech
city and tech is dominated by men and
men who make a lot of money and it
just wasn't it wasn't as amenable to the
existence of the lexington club anymore
um people you know every lesbian i knew
he went to blex lexington club like
shacked up with somebody moved to
oakland got a dog like they're not going
to the lex anymore you know they can't
live in san francisco anymore anyway
so the reason that you understand why
i'm just the first time i'm trying to
actually draw this parallel
is that i think like in order to
preserve the lexington club you would
have had to have a mass
a mass anti-capitalist politics in san
francisco that made it possible for the
city to remain
amenable to this particular marginalized
group like actually hanging around
right and keeping its own institutions
alive
and that's the goal of cosmopolitan
socialism is to actually make it
possible for people to experience their
own cultures
um and also experience each other's
cultures and i will say on the whole
self-segregation point
one thing that i loved about the
lexington club in the early 2010s
is that there would be people because it
had a pool table and the doors were
always open
people would come in who were not
lesbians and they would play pool and it
was not an issue it was [ __ ] great
but you know what they would hear
they would hear like you know like uh
like they would hear like lesbian bands
being played
like or just like really classic queer
like punk music being played
over over the stereo like that's the
kind of vision of cosmopolitan socialism
that we're talking about to
not literally but also as a metaphor if
that makes sense yeah no it does
i should say that uh when it comes to
victor and uh you you'll always get a
rise out of us whenever it comes to a
save
our bar uh kind of uh project right uh
yes a lot of my formative
experiences were in bars as ourselves
but you know i think that's a great
example
of exactly what we're talking about and
actually this program is the last thing
i want us to talk about which is
the way that a cosmopolitan socialism
can defend difference
that's distinct from the way for
instance that the political right
approaches
difference right because there's a
conservative argument you can make
for respecting a certain kind of
particularism
uh nationalists make arguments like this
all the time i'm thinking of somebody
like joramizoni
but what's distinctive about the kind of
conservative arguments for difference
is precisely that they want a kind of
silo difference right
we have our group in our space in our
nation in our country
and you have yours over there and we
don't interact with one another at all
whereas when i think of cosmopolitan
socialism it's precisely that we can
take
pride uh and a certain degree of joy in
the existence of
difference in our community um including
manifest cultural difference
because that's an opportunity for us to
learn and develop as people
so i lived in mexico for a couple of
years so i spent a lot of time in the
lgbt community in mexico which was quite
a learning experience for me let me tell
you for
and several different metrics right but
what really struck me by doing this
uh was how this wasn't just an abstract
ideology which i think is how we
sometimes approach
difference when we're not really exposed
to it these are people they had
different opinions different lifestyles
different hopes different dreams
and i learned from them by interacting
with them one-on-one
and i don't think i would have been able
to develop in that way unless i had this
kind of exposure i was actually able to
learn from them in this one-on-one way
right so when i think of cosmopolitan
socialism these are the kind of
opportunities that come to my mind right
the chance to really engage with other
people who feel very differently and
live very different lives than you
in your community and use the
experiments in life that they're
engaging in
to inform your own existence and try to
develop as a person which is very
different
in my perspective than the kind of
conservative siloed approach to
difference that you'll see people like
nationalists make
i'm sorry the kind of uh positions that
nationalists want to take
so i'm not sure what you think about
that victor does that sound plausible
yeah i mean i think that also like those
experiences i mean
you know i've had similar experiences
but i think like what you actually
realize
is uh kind of like also that this there
i mean it's cheesy to say but like the
sameness right like the fact that
actually we all have uh
like shared interest and i think maybe
that's what's at the core
of uh of cosmopolitan socialism right is
that yeah like there's these
i mean you know you don't want to call
them they're not superficial differences
right there's like real kind of like
lifestyle or
differences about like practices that
are going to lead to
some conception of what the good life is
going to be for you but then ultimately
like the
fact that we all want the the the um the
circumstances and the material
conditions to live that good life
that's all shared in common um and i
think like maybe that's what those
those experiences um kind of reveal i
suppose
i'll also add that i mean while we're on
i guess it's i've been maybe over
criticizing the left a little bit here
because i think the right deserves far
more criticism for like
this kind of like like you said matt for
enforcing this kind of like
difference as a difference as a pretext
for
separation or segregation but the left
falls into that trap
a lot of the time too um and yeah i
think one of the
things that is concerning about that
is that there does seem to be sometimes
in some left spaces
a kind of um social
reward system for noticing and even
dramatizing
differences between people who live
lives that on a global
on a global scale are quite similar to
each other
sometimes i do think about the fact that
like um
differences between myself and other
people for example will be exaggerated
over like twitter right and i'm like
very aware that the person who's doing
that is like also at a white collar job
typing on their macbook
telling me that we could never possibly
see eye to eye that we
we could that i couldn't possibly
understand a single thing about their
experience and so on and so forth
and it does strike me that um primarily
on twitter
never never it strikes me that the two
of us
live lives that are like so similar
compared to
a like garment worker in bangladesh or
like a rice farmer in vietnam or just
there are so many people on this world
who live lives that are so different and
i even feel and perhaps it sounds
it sounds naive but i even feel that i
have
something critical in common with
a garment worker in bangladesh and a
rice and a rice field worker in vietnam
and that it is our responsibility to
uncover
uncover what it is that we share in
common and to emphasize that in our
mutual struggle for a better world for
all of us
i know that sounds kind of pollyanna-ish
i think that it's actually kind of sad
that it sounds pollyannaish but i think
that's like maybe is a
is a reflection on like the the sorry
state of universalist
discourse on the left is that it's kind
of like hand waved away i think that
it's kind of
been maligned this kind of discourse
about you know like
shared humanity and common good has been
maligned as kind of like
woo woo like um unthinking
unserious um like
um like nostrums you know just like
problem
right um it's kind of it kind of people
when they hear stuff like that they kind
of think like oh right and we're all
from mother africa right
like that's that's the impression that
people get but i i really again i don't
i think we can't throw the baby out with
the bathwater because the truth the
matter is that we are facing
a global ecological crisis and also
capitalism is a global system that
requires
people to fight it in tandem with each
other all across the globe it literally
will not work our resistance to
capitalism will not work if it's nation
by nation
so we do are we are going to have to
find um
find it within ourselves to get over
um our condescension toward these um
notions of like a shared or common
humanity right it's actually very
critical that we actually um
um elevate them over over what divides
us
yeah i i have thoughts about you know
why why that is i mean i think
it's so true uh this hand waving away
and kind of sneering
at that attitude and i think there's
probably like two main reasons because i
think about this
a lot um and i think one of them is i
mean we do live in this age of i think
cynicism
where we kind of value there it's funny
i always notice and i think twitter
makes this worse and social media makes
it worse that there's like a
it's like you know being cynical and
kind of being a doomer about how bad
everything is
is like is it's almost like i don't know
if it's a requisite for being cool but
it almost seems like it's
it's it's it's it's a it's a component
of like okay like he gets it it's like
if you're seeing how terrible everything
is
and like you know i think that that idea
that you outlined that we've been
talking
about there's an optimism to it and i
think that optimism is a little bit out
uh like in it's out of fashion a little
bit
and i think part of the reason for that
too is probably that
obviously we all know that there's a
huge history
of uh you know western civilization
western imperialism
right using the idea that this is for
the common good right in the past like
conquest and all these things so like
there's i think also a kind of
aftershock of being like hey they lied
to us when they said that this was in
the common good when they said they were
going to come and colonize us
right and it's like so then there's like
a skepticism to that idea
um yeah but yeah i just wanted to end uh
with this and then i'll let
megan have the last word um i think
that's one of the reasons why michael's
work in particular resonated with so
many people because
he could be a very cynical extremely
critical guy and you saw that in his
programming right nobody got angry uh
like he did
he was kind of optimistic at heart i
remember when i talked to him he was
really upbeat really interested in a lot
of things
uh took joy in a lot of the stuff that
he was engaging in
fascinated uh by taoism uh and various
kinds of
spiritual practices and doing so in a
sincere and respectful way and i found
that really refreshing
since a lot of the people i encounter on
the left are very cynical
and very angry sometimes and it can be a
bit of a
frustrating thing sometimes for me as a
leftist but what i wanted to say is um
as a conclusion is this whole
conversation has reminded me a bit of
terry eagleton's critique
of militant particularism in his book
illusions of post-modernism
uh where he says that look the kind of
siloing that some leftists want
actually echoes the kind of approach to
difference that you'd find in the work
of conservative authors
you know people like edmund burke joseph
de maestra um
even someone like michael oakshott on
occasion right where there's this idea
that
as megan put it we all have our lane and
we stick to it and
the best kind of culture is one that's
uniform homogeneous
and doesn't interact with any others and
i can understand as victor said the
temptation to maybe want to go that
route
given the perils of universalism and its
association with imperialism through the
19th and 20th century
but i think that the kind of
cosmopolitanism that we all seem to be
wanting
is something that's much more in line
with kwame appia's conception of it
which is that we respect culture and
difference but we respect them
because we recognize that culture is
important to
other human beings who are very much
like us and just as we would
want our culture and our practices and
our individual uh particularities to be
wiped out uh so too we have to we
wouldn't want them sorry yeah
so too uh we don't want to see that
happen to other people
so that's the way i would conceive of
the kind of moral grounding uh for
cosmopolitan socialism
i mean i think that's as good a place to
end it as any but since you're giving me
the last word i'll build off of that and
say that i think that
um i think that actually a lot of people
on the left
um probably agree with us they just get
caught in a kind of
like social or um conversational logic
that cuts
against it and and to to to this point
to evidence this point i would say that
if people actually really look into
their souls and ask themselves
why they became socialists to begin with
if we're talking about socialists in
particular i think that at base
it's because you know that a person who
has you know multiple millions of
dollars is
fundamentally the same as a person
who's flat broke and that it's ex the
the way that our society is structured
does not actually reflect that
and that's what makes you angry and that
is the thing that is that's the core
of your political orientation actually
when you boil it down that's the core of
your political orientation if you're a
socialist
is that you know that there are there
are people who are living lives of
luxury and there are people who are
toiling and being exploited and the at
base
they are both the same type of entity
which is just a person
and that's that's not fair and so you
actually do understand
somewhere deep inside yourself you do
understand that this common morality is
actually the root or the soul of
socialism
or sorry this common humanity um is the
root or the soul of socialism
and the task is simply to try to like
bring that out and practice
not just as a sort of like basic
assumption from which everything else
flows right okay well thanks a lot megan
for coming on
the pillpot we'll provide the links uh
to your articles
uh but solidarity i really enjoyed this
conversation and i'm hoping that we can
have many more in the future
yeah thanks so much megan that was great
thank you guys so much it was such a
[Music]
blast
you